outside China Italy is the country with
the most reported infections and deaths
from the corona virus so in a desperate
bid to stop the disease from spreading
the entire country is now in a lockdown
it's the most severe restriction on
movement in Italy since world war ii
Charlie d'Agata is in Rome Charlie what
is it like there now good morning
Anthony just take a look at the Piazza
del Popolo I know you've been here the
People's Square not today the Prime
Minister here has described the
situation quoting Winston Churchill as
Italy's darkest hour if anyone wants to
see what a worst-case scenario looks
like look no further than Italy it was
the news a nation already on its knees
was dreading but as the crisis deepened
it felt inevitable the announcement
triggered a rash of panic buying here in
Rome as shoppers and masks swarmed
supermarkets in fear of a countrywide
lockdown in Houma in a national address
prime minister Giuseppe Conte spelled it
out in the starkest terms we have run
out of time he said we're having a
growth in infections and deaths the
whole of Italy will become a protected
zone in essence a quarantine of the
entire country of 60 million people
until next month
here's what life under lockdown means
travel across Italy severely restricted
all public gatherings of any kind
strictly forbidden employees should work
from home or approved to police why
they're not restaurants and shops will
shut their doors after dusk the
extension of the shutdown of schools and
universities across the country
violators risk up to three months in
jail or fines of $225 the extreme
measures after the number of cases
jumped once again now the most
infections outside of China more than
9,000 cases 463 people have died
officials in the hardest at northern
regions say hospitals are on the verge
of collapse
this morning we spoke with an 88 year
old with pre-existing conditions Giorgio
Pina who's been stuck inside his house
since the original shutdown are you
scared yes everybody's scared now if
there is some good news to report there
are some reassuring signs that extreme
measures like these are working across
some of the northern zones where this
quarantine has been in place for a
couple of weeks the numbers there are
actually going down Michelle we hope
those measures do work Charlie d'Agata
in Rome thank you